a commencé sa marche à blanc il y a dix
jours il ne lui en fallait pas plus pour
convaincre ses dpq infras on a encore 21
jours devant nous pour la compléter mais
déjà les premiers jours les jours qui
ont précédé ont été vraiment concluant
satisfaisant c'est la raison pour
laquelle on est très confortable avec
l'annonce d'une date le 31 juillet
prochain ça commence aussi ouais 31
juillet
les tests se poursuivront jusqu'au 31
juillet ensuite le REM entrera en
période de rodage avec cette fois-ci des
humains à bord mais c'est certain que le
facteur humain ça implique peut-être des
gens par exemple qui ont des malaises à
bord du train donc il y a des gens par
tête qui achètent qui bloque des ports
donc c'est ça aussi qu'on doit tester
lors de la période de rodage au cabinet
de la ministre des Transports on se
réjouit qu'une date soit finalement
confirmée pour le lancement du REM on
espérait que le service soit bien en sel
avant la rentrée et c'était donc
essentiel de faire le rodage en nous la
mairesse de Brossard est emballée par la
nouvelle
tellement fébrile j'attendais avec
impatience la date l'important pour moi
pour le Conseil bien sûr c'est que ça se
passe avant la rentrée scolaire c'est
des PQ infra affirment avoir tout fait
pour éviter le fiasco du train léger
d'Ottawa notre situation est
complètement différente de la situation
de Ottawa je rappelle que nous avons
passé à trois tests de trois saisons
hivernales de test nous avons pris le
temps à chaque fois de s'assurer que
toutes les mesures étaient prises que
les niveaux de performance était au
rendez-vous ou si pour répondre aux
citoyens de Pointe Saint-Charles
dérangés par le bruit des trains c'est
des PQ infras a déjà commandé des murs
anti-bruit mais il demeure un mystère le
prix pour l'ensemble du REM en juin 2021
il s'élevait à 6,9 milliards de dollars
la facture promet donc d'être plus salée
parce qu'on a toujours pas inclu les
coûts reliés à la pandémie à l'inflation
et à la réflexion d'infrastructures
centenaires comme le tunnel Mont-Royal
ici Marie-Josée paquet como Radio-Canada
Brossard